[Music]
so yeah I I grew a bit obvious obviously
this isn't just any bit by the way this
is a thesis beard specifically the rule
of the thesis beard is you don't shave
until you hand in and I haven't been
doing this for all my PhD because I I
would probably like Gandalf this has
been that six weeks worth of growth
which I realized is kind of pathetic but
this is this is just my genetics by the
way I get nothing on the sides like I
haven't shaved this I do like I get
barely anything and it's like it just it
just it just looks like I've got paint
splats on my face on the side so I just
I shaved those bits like this this isn't
a style choice this is just what might
be a does I am forever condemned to be
like a Poundland dr. strange I'm still
getting used to it and I'm gonna lie
like looking at myself in the viewfinder
now it it doesn't look like me and this
is something that pixel go has said it's
just like whatever she sees me it's like
I feel like I'm cheating on you with a
guy with a beard because Simon is not a
person that has a beard and I think what
this has proved is the Simon is it's not
a person who should have appeared do you
let me know if you like it by the way
this is to split opinion on my Twitter
like oh no my strobe light before people
seem to either really like it really
dislike it so let me know what you think
I'm gonna shave it off at the end of the
PhD because I'm desperate to get this
thing off my face but you know if you
nice to know if it looked nice or not
now you might very well ask why did you
do this to yourself Simon and I can
answer that in a word which is curiosity
I I was curious
I'd never grown a bit before I grew a
very creepy mustache in my final year at
Oxford for Movember and if my PhD runs
into November I might just shave this
bottom bit off and go back to that which
was you know such a killer that last
time but yeah I was curious what I'd
look like and also just what it's like
to have a beard I had a few observations
about having a beard one beard have--is
there must be a word for that
I don't think there is a word for
somebody who just just has a beard I
think a hirsute is probably the closest
thing just on who is hairy see ya beard
hammers of the world how do you drink
from cans like this is the biggest thing
I found over the past six weeks
everytime and it is basically every time
I try and drink from
like a normal wrinkle can I leave bits
of my beard in it this might sound like
a small problem and a little bit gross
it hurts like it really hurts only rip
part of your face off second point that
does seem to be like a fraternity of of
beard hovers as this guy who works at
reception who has this as well what my
friend lovingly called a toilet seat
beard I think he saw me after I started
crying it was just like all right so of
course I was just like yeah no words
being said but it's like yeah we are
it's like it's like people with some
bikers do this wouldn't let you pass
bikers on the road if you're driving if
you're riding a motorbike you're just
like hey you're right same with Land
Rovers people who drive Land Rovers we
humans are weird like that it's like we
really desire like to belong to a
collective to belong to something I
guess it's how like gang's form but like
I feel really like I'm I'm a an initiate
pseudo member of this great beard
fraternity which has been cool thirdly
that was definitely a nadir like two
weeks in when to begin with because
either thing I should point out as I did
a time lapse of this beard growing and
to begin with it just looks like stubble
and then it obviously it grows a bit but
I felt like there was a point about two
weeks in where I just look like a hobo
basically I look like I hadn't I just
hadn't shaved because I couldn't be
bothered and now by now it's like oh
yeah that person is trying to grow a
beard I'm not gonna say that I have a
beard I think that's generous but like
yeah two weeks in not good would not
recommend but like you know it gets
better well again I don't think this is
this constitutes much better
and then lastly I've learned that there
are lots of weird things you can do to
make your beard grow because
understandably I mean look at this I was
just like I've got to do everything I
can to try and get something on my face
and it turns out there's loads of things
you can do if you exfoliate it
stimulates blood flow to the face and
that means your beard grows faster um
certain vitamins are very important so
I've been taking multivitamins exercise
is important for the same reason that's
like exfoliating so it promotes
increases your blood flow so I've been
running more then how much of a
difference it's made but it's kind of
weird how like for any particular thing
like it doesn't matter what you want
your body to do there will be a specific
set of instructions some on the internet
that's just like yep you need to do this
this this and this
doesn't necessarily mean it'll work to
return to the point about curiosity
though the reason I'm doing this really
is because I'm doing a thesis right I'm
doing a PhD thesis and the reason I'm
doing that is because I'm curious about
the world
I guess that's that's that's the
fundamental thing right I just wanted to
know how the world worked so I found
myself in the situation where I'm
writing a 150 page document that's
eating my life and ended up with this
small woodland animal on my face you
know it's not something that all PhD
students have to do I mean like the
women in particular would struggle but
it's something I wanted to do and so
like that's why I feel like this thing
is about curiosity because I was curious
what I look like with a beard and I was
provided with an opportunity to justify
it by being curious about the world with
my thesis and when you match them
together you get you get a beak wrap it
curiosity is also the reason why this
video exists at all and that's because
as I said at the start of the video this
is a sponsored video and it's sponsored
by Merc Merc have just launched an
initiative to encourage curiosity in the
scientific world and I was actually
involved in this initiative in a series
called curious minds where I was
interviewed in Berlin which she was seen
in the last vlog I put out about
curiosity and about how curiosity is
influenced my professional scientific
life and about how it has allowed me to
be creative in solving problems and come
up with stuff that's going into my
thesis and I was being interviewed by my
good friend in a store s'en she wasn't
just interviewing me though she was
interviewing a whole bunch of really
interesting people who have used
curiosity in their work in some way or
other and all the videos although all
those interviews can be included down
there along with a link to the curiosity
hub honestly I'd highly recommend you
check it out when they show me the
website I was really impressed it
doesn't cost anything I don't think you
need to register it's just a series of
tools that are designed to train your
curiosity to kind of which is a weird
thing in itself right can kiosk to be
trained that's one of the questions in
the interview I think it can be which is
just as well because there are these
tools on the website that allow you to
hone different bits of your curiosity
and you get something called curiosity
report but that's all of the link down
there thank you very much tumeric for
sponsoring this video and for the
amazing time that I had in Berlin and
thank you for watching this video
hopefully the next time you see me this
beard won't be long for the world Oh
dietary finish the thesis Simon
[Music]
[Music]